heute meine damen und herren ist wieder
zeit für den philosophischen stammtisch
war ohne bier und bytes dafür mit
gepfefferten argumenten
denn eines kann ich ihnen versprechen
einig werden wir uns heute nicht
und das bei einem thema bei dem es ans
lebendige geht nämlich beim thema
freitodbegleitung die freitodbegleitung
ist auch thema des schweizer tatorts der
heute abend um 58 auf sf 1 ausgestrahlt
wird
anlass für uns vorab einen
philosophischen argumente check zu
machen
mit von der partie sind unsere
stammgäste die sie bereits kennen café
numark aus berlin
konrad paul liessmann aus wien und als
gast heute bei uns am tisch peter
schaber ist professor für philosophie
und ethik zentrum der universität zürich
um der beschäftigt sich seit jahren mit
dem thema menschenwürde auch
selbstbestimmung unter anderem am
lebensende herzlich willkommen
ja peter sauber dass hier sind die
utensilien die man braucht wenn man eine
freitodbegleitung durchführen will
stellen sie sich vor sie nehmen dieses
pulver lösen auf im wasserglas rühren um
trinken das glas was letztlich
vorstellungen aus wer schon etwas
sonderbares dass man etwas tut von dem
man weiß dass es das eigene leben
beenden wird
das ist deshalb sonderbaren
üblicherweise der tod etwas ist das wir
nicht planen das über uns kommt dass ein
wieder freies ist und hier ist es in
meiner eigenen kontrolle das zu tun das
ist sicherlich sonderbar habhaft unfähig
ist sicherlich eine befremdliche
vorstellung dass man das selber schuld
da kann man sich wahrscheinlich nicht so
leicht an vleuten mit
ich hab schon angetönt der tat dort
heute abend zum thema suizidbegleitung
zum thema sterbetourismus es geht um
eine frau unter anderem die reist aus
deutschland an in begleitung ihrer
tochter ist selber schwer krank lässt
eine freitodbegleitung durchführen am
rande der stadt in einem wohnblock am
tag darauf wird die sterbebegleiterin
tot aufgefunden es ist ein
das ist der platz des tatorts schauen
wir uns die anfangsszene an in der die
suizidbegleitung vorgenommen wird was
immer sie bereits
[Musik]
aus juristischen gründen kommt in
unseren safe
[Musik]
nun ist nicht kalt kind
das ist fiktion ausschnitt aus dem
tatort von märklin wir mal an das wäre
jetzt realität welche personen möchten
sie am wenigsten gern sein
ich glaube die person die begleitet dass
es schwieriger die tochter ich glaube
dass es ja dazu gibt's auch untersuchen
und dann hat das ja auch es ist für die
leute die einen menschen auch liebevoll
in den freitod begleiten glaube ich
schwer war
weil sie sozusagen damit umgehen müssen
dass jemand eben diese entscheidung in
die hand genommen hat und sie müssen das
auch danach dass das ist glaube ich
wirklich eine schwere position also
damit umzugehen wie immer gut ich dass
rational auch nachvollziehen kann dass
diese person entschieden hat zu sterben
aufgrund ihrer schweren leidens dass sie
sich mir entzogen hat ich glaube darin
liegt eine große große kränkung in eine
große traurigkeit und das finde ich hart
hingegen glaube ich umgekehrt dass ich
die bei meinem jetzigen alter noch nicht
wahnsinnig aktuelle frage aber trotzdem
ich glaube die die handlung selber des
suizids die würde mir nicht stefan die
die es mir gängig und geläufig in meinem
inneren repertoire ständig die eine
logische und auch richtige entscheidung
in gewissen situationen herr ließ man
bis zwei ihnen welche personen würden
sie nicht sein wollen
ich würde auf keinen fall die person
sein wollen
die die mittel bereitstellt für diesen
suizid
ich will ja auch sonst davor
zurückschreckten beihilfe zu einem mord
zu leisten
wobei das natürlich schon genau die
hände der entscheidenden philosophischen
fragen ist welche akt geschieht hier
eigentlich
wir haben wir hier interessanten
sozusagen bedeutungswandel vorgenommen
in letzter zeit sehr sehr lange sprachen
werden fehlen von selbstmord das klingt
das mittlerweile andere wir sprechen
sehr euphemistisch freitod das so gut
freiheit selbstbewusste autonome
entscheidung das kann ja nichts
schlimmes sein
ich denke dass durch solche begriffs
färbungen oder einfärben
natürlich auch bestimmte bestimmten
wandel unserer einstellungen dazu
dokumentieren aber ich möchte nicht
sozusagen im geschäft der sterbehilfe
tätig sein
die anderen argumente kann ich durchaus
nachvollziehen ja also ich kann
nachvollziehen dass wir angehöriger das
ein riesenproblem ist genau aus dem
grund denn sie genannt haben
für mich selber gehört sagen der freitod
des selbstmords das lied nicht zum
gängigen repertoire von
handlungsoptionen
wie also etwa zum friseur gehen nach
zürich fliegen ein buch lesen vorlesung
halten
handlungsoptionen ja nein sondern es
wäre wenn überhaupt dann tatsächlich ein
extremist ja es wäre die extremste
situation wo sich diese frage für mich
stellen könnte wobei ich natürlich aus
der philosophiegeschichte der
philosophischen diskussion des suizids
kenne und seit der antike wird das als
eine ultima ratio menschliche
handlungsmöglichkeit gesehen allerdings
hat sich hier auch geändert sondern
welche rahmenbedingungen gegeben sein
müssen damit diese unter marazzi
plausibilität gewinnt es ist vielleicht
wirklich lehrreich zur untersuchung aus
welchen gründen haben sich menschen in
der antike umgebracht das wären gründen
töten wir uns heute selbst wer ganz
interessant historischen 1
es ist schon eine menge auf dem tisch
bleiben mal kurz bei diesem punkt dass
sie angezweifelt haben dass das was zu
tun haben könnte mit freiheit haben
gesagt freitod ist ein euphemismus herr
schaber ich sowas ein ausdruck von
freiheit also zunächst muss ich noch
eine bemerkung machen so der
begrifflichen punkt zum selbstmord wir
reden tatsächlich weniger von selbstmord
heutzutage eher von selbsttötung oder
ganz vom freitod
und ich glaube da gibt es auch gute
gründe dafür den mord ist wird verstand
möglicherweise als das töten eines
menschen aus niederträchtigen motiven
heraus und mir scheint diese
beschreibung
trifft auf auf auf die selbsttötung wenn
ich jetzt diesen begriff vorziehe wohl
kaum zu in der regel sind die gründe
wieso menschen das tun haben mit
niedertracht überhaupt nichts zu tun das
wollte ich noch nach
deshalb habe ich ist das ganz sinnvoll
nicht mehr von selbstmord zu reden
sondern von schon selbst völlig
einverstanden ein wenig der verstanden
und zwar jetzt nicht aus dem wegen des
zweiten argument dass erst ein argument
das heißt ich kann glaube ich muss nicht
nur reduzieren auf rettung aus
niederträchtigen motiven
aber ich weiß nicht welche motive es
gibt jemanden zu töten und die weiß
nicht wer über diese motivlage
entscheidet also ich finde mal mord mal
prinzipiell die absichtliche tötung
eines menschen in der regel die
rechtliche definition ist eben aus
niederträchtig motiven motiven zum
beispiel der bereicherung oder andere
motive die man eben als schlecht
beurteilt also ist die standard
auffassung und die scheint mir einfach
nicht anwendbar zu sein auf die
selbsttötung nicht nur was niedertracht
ist es selbst dass er kurierte wisst ja
vorstellen dass was nicht das machen da
gemeint ist reich wären ja dass jede
tötung eines menschen
morgen wäre also dass diese
unterscheidung nicht aufsteht und
absichtlich ja wir kennen ja schon ein
unterschied zwischen mord oder totschlag
gegeben
wenn wir jede absichtliche tötung aber
da gibt es auch schon da muss man doch
glaube ich schon eine feine
unterscheidung machen also auch die
sozen passive sterbehilfe also wenn ich
oder ich meine auch diese ganzen
juristischen beispiel ist natürlich ein
bisschen an den haaren herbeigezogen
sind aber es gibt eine situation zum
beispiel dieses beispiel jemand
verbrennt in einem auto ich kann ihn
nicht retten ist es dann nicht irgendwie
richtig dass ich ihn erschossen
dieser anschluss es gibt möglichkeiten
es gibt situationen wo wir einen
menschen töten wo ich das nicht machen
würde ich würde das auch das ist
natürlich dann bei der abtreibung
diskussion eine andere frage ob das ein
mensch ist aber das würde ich auch nicht
morgen einen wenn man einen embryo
abtreibt und da gibt es verschiedene
gute gründe kann jetzt auch verschiedene
lassen sie mich an dieser stelle eine
zuschauerin zu wort kommen die zuschauer
in magdalena frevel die hat uns im
vorfeld geschrieben was ich beim thema
sterbehilfe nicht verstehe ist warum
sich viele so schwer tun mit dem
wunsch dass ein mensch selber
entscheiden will wann er sterben möchte
weil es eben doch eine entscheidung ist
die anders ist als andere
lebensentscheidungen und ich glaube das
ist auch das was wir hier ist man ja so
ein bisschen unterstellt hat das mit dem
friseur und dem nach zürich fliegen also
das fällt mir deutlich leichter als der
suizid tatsächlich ich glaube eher dass
es ich hätte jetzt gesagt das ist eine
möglichkeit die vielleicht eher wie
heiraten oder kinderkriegen ist das eine
lebensentscheidung die tatsächlich nicht
so ganz richtig rückgängig machbar ist
und sie selten aber noch mehr als
heiraten oder kinder kriegen das ist ja
eine entscheidung aus dem leben zu gehen
also es ist eben eine entscheidung kann
grundsätzlich anders ist als jede andere
entscheidung die wir im leben treffen
also ich finde sie deswegen tun wir uns
schwer an ich glaube schon weil es
sozusagen also eine gewisse in gewisser
weise empfinden viele menschen diese
entscheidung als größer bedeutender und
und so sind auch nicht rückgängig machen
und in dem sinne anders als andere
entscheidungen und dann also natürlich
kann man jetzt noch kultur ist durch
alles mögliche an führen ich glaube da
ist der einfluss einer kirchlichen ethik
einer kirchlichen moral die ebenso kann
die unverfügbarkeit des eigenen
menschlichen lebens sehr stark gemacht
hat um die in unsere kultur natürlich
sehr vorhanden ist ist stark aber ich
glaube trotzdem dass ist auch man das
dazu sind ja eigentlich die umfragewerte
auch relativ klar mittlerweile natürlich
gibt es menschen die das noch ablehnen
aber es gibt eben doch eigentlich einen
großen anteil von menschen die dem auch
zustimmen diese möglichkeit der freiheit
ich glaube wir tun uns schwer aus
einerseits weil es eine tatsächlich
wichtige entscheidung ist der
entscheidung über leben oder tod habe
ich dann aber auch dass eine tradition
wirksam ist die glaube ich immer noch
wirksam ist
die halt selbsttötung oder selbstmord
wie sie je mehr wollen verurteilt hat
über jahrhunderte und das beginnt sich
jetzt so langsam zu wandeln
aber wir dürfen natürlich nicht
vergessen wenn wir zurückblicken in
kulturgeschichte für die sowie
geschichte war das dominante urteil der
selbstmörder begeht nicht nur
möglicherweise einen fehler aus
kulanzgründen sondern tut etwas was
moralisch verwerflich ist das war die
standard einschätzung die lange zeit
vorherrscht und ich glaube dass wir in
gewisser weise immer noch unter diesem
einfluss stehen es gibt auf der einen
seite die das was sie jetzt standard
einschätzung nennen natürlich auch die
christlich geprägte oder religiös
geprägte vorstellen dass das eine sünde
ist aber gleichzeitig catalis man ja
auch schon erwähnt dass es in der
philosophiegeschichte natürlich auch die
prominenten personen gibt denken wir
beispielsweise an sokrates denken wir
aber auch an nietzsche die die meinung
vertreten haben mein tod gehört mir und
es hat etwas durchaus edles dann aus dem
leben zu scheiden wenn möglicherweise
einfach das leben auch für andere
sozusagen eine belastung wird mein
leiden eine belastung wird für andere
oder ich zum beispiel mich verleugnen
wir das im falle von sokrates er hätte
sei es eine lehre zurückziehen müssen
und hat an den becher gewählt können sie
dieser position philosophisch gesehen
nichts nichts anbringen einigkeit all
diesen positionen was bringen mir geht
es nur einfach zu schnell und zu klar
das war auch dass er sagen mein
vorheriger einwand jetzt nicht unbedingt
dafür selbstmord wie in der tradition
von einer gewissen tradition als sind ja
auch zu fassen sondern wir darauf
hinzuweisen wie wir hier auch also zu
sagen einstellungsänderungen durch
begriffs verschiebungen vornehmen und
mich interessieren die motive dahinter
und wir sehen ja schon bei den
beispielen wie schwierig es ist bei
stock hatte sogar das nicht selbstmord
begangen so hat es hat sozusagen ein
gerichtsurteil hat sich einem
gerichtsurteil unterworfen ja es war ein
relativ 1 1 ein todesurteil
man hat sich nur dazu durchgerungen
damals ihn nicht zu kürzen oder ihn
nicht zu erstechen auch in sich zu
erhängen die möglichkeit zu geben
studiums becher zu trinken das ist das
todesurteil an sich selbst zu
vollstrecken
das was anderes als ein freitod oder
auch das argument was sie gebracht haben
es gibt mir schon zu denken ob das
wirklich ein plausibler grund sein kann
sich zu töten wenn man angst hat anderen
nicht zur last zu fallen ja das war
eines der argumente für die euthanasie
nationalsozialismus das heißt also was
ist das sozusagen ist das jetzt die
freie entscheidung des einzelnen oder
hängt das viel mehr auch wenn nicht viel
mehr sondern zumindest auch
davon ab was die soziale umgebung als
belastend empfinden bearbeitet und
natürlich kann ich das ist wahrlich auch
relevant also jungs sagt das ja auch
eindeutig also es kann auch für mich ein
persönliches argument sein dass ich ihr
schweine entlasten würde aber noch ganz
vage ist dass in dem man sehr schnell
jemanden zu last fällt aber ich glaube
also da würde ich wirklich es davor
warnen die nationalsozialistischen
euthanasie hier rein zu bringen also die
wahl nicht programm was dazu beitrug
leuten nicht zur last zu fallen
das ist ein mord programm was wir
wirklich separat ziehen sollten von
einer heutigen und auch einer
philosophischen freitod diskussion ich
glaube da wird viel begriffs vermischung
betrieben die auch unschön ist und im
übrigen nur noch wann genau der
unterschied dafür tun also die
euthanasie das ist ein 1 1 sozusagen ein
staatlich organisiertes programm womit
man lebensunwertes leben also behinderte
menschen menschen die man zum teil ja
auch also wirklich das ist sehr
kompliziert was die nationalsozialisten
und lebensunwerten alles verstanden
umgebracht hat und das ist weder freitod
das ist auch nicht in unserem sinne
aktive sterbehilfe von jemand der
sterben möchte
das ist ein mord programm das mit einer
sozialen menschenverachtenden ideologie
zusammenhängt und wenn ich das jetzt bei
menschen mit einer heutigen diskussion
darüber was ärztliche grenzen sind was
so an mir als mensch zu steht frei zu
entscheiden ob ich dieses medikament
hier nehme ob ich ein arzt bitten darf
mir dieses medikament zu gehen oder
sogar wie es zum beispiel in den
niederlanden möglich ist ein arzt bitten
darf mir eine spritze zu verabreichen
wenn ich es selber nicht mehr aktiv ist
das wäre aktiv und das hat alles finde
ich mit so etwas wie einem
nationalsozialistischen ideologischen
wahnsinn waren system nichts zu tun und
ich glaube es ist tatsächlich gefährlich
wenn wir dieses hier immer wieder
einbringen als irgendwie gefahr die am
horizont schweben würde und muss jetzt
was sagen dazu ich möchte es nicht
vermischen ja ich finde es aber genauso
gefährlich so zu tun als hätten unsere
argumentation ein und muss für
diskussionen gar nichts damit zu tun
dass stimmt rein historisch nicht ja ich
habe jetzt in vorbereitung dieser
diskussion etwa noch einmal angesehen
dann übrigens schwer zugänglichen viel
mit klagen
ein propaganda für nationalsozialisten
von 1941 entstanden im zusammenhang mit
diesen euthanasie programmen und dieser
film ließe sich eins zu eins heute
verwenden als propagandafilm für freitod
denn es geht in der tat darum dass eine
von einer tödlichen krankheit verfallen
eine junge frau ihren mann der zufällig
arztes inständig bittet sie von diesem
land zu lösen sie will nicht mehr leben
und es geht wirklich darum das soll man
ihr jetzt dem selbstmord beistehen
klassischer fall von suizid assistenz
auf wunsch dieser person sollen wir
hierbei stehen oder soll mir nicht mehr
zu lösen
die nicht viel das ist hochinteressant
da das ist kurz sagen der film sozusagen
der arzt tötet dann seine frau er wird
vor gericht gestellt
ja und der film lässt es offen wie die
richterin er lässt es offen auf 14 41
aber natürlich gehört der film genau in
diese diskussion und auch hier und das
war das war mal ein anknüpfungspunkt ist
auch ganz stark das argument auf ich
will meiner umwelt nicht will meiner
familie
ich gehe in einer gesellschaft ich liebe
meinen start im leben nicht mehr zur
last fallen und das war ja ihr argument
man kann ja vielleicht sagen über diese
über diese frage ob es diese in diesen
trend sozusagen geht und dabei eine
menschen unter druck gesetzt werden
lassen sie uns darüber nachher noch
sprechen lassen sie uns die debatte
jetzt noch umkehren also ich würde gerne
umgekehrt wissen was sind denn die
kriterien dafür dass so ein freitod sag
ich jetzt wirklich freiwillig sein kann
also würden sie sagen das ist gar nicht
möglich selbst wer das immer möglich
natürlich nein ich meine dass jemand das
eben nicht aufgrund von drucksituationen
macht sondern weil er das für sich
wünscht also der dreh und angelpunkt in
der debatte ist die selbstbestimmung
was ist selbstbestimmung herr schaber in
diesem kontext erscheint das ist ein
wichtiger begriff und und und deshalb
eines darum geht zunächst mal dass man
sicherstellen
in der praxis die wir beispielsweise
hier in der schweiz mit begleitetem
stärken haben dadurch spielt ja auch der
will man sich jetzt entscheidung
freiwillig ist das muss eine eigene
entscheidung sein das ist mit
selbstbestimmung gemeint und was ist
dafür war spielt dafür eine rolle ich
glaube dass man das daran feststellen
kann was die leute für gründe nennen die
leute mit wem man redet ja mit den
betroffenen menschen die das wollen und
fragt sich auch wie so sie denn in ihrem
leben ein ende setzen und hört dann die
gründe an und es gibt ja auch ansprechen
die untersuchungen welche gründe
menschen nennen und ich glaube dass man
diesen gründen klar fest machen kann ob
eine entscheidung freiwillig ist oder
nicht freilich ist und dass das
natürlich eingefordert werden muss es
gar keine frage
und deshalb werde ich auch sagen hat die
praxis die wir heute haben mit der
praxis die wir gerade diskutiert haben
der asylpraxis das ist wirklich gar
nichts zu tun und ich muss ehrlich sagen
ich würde mich also massiv dagegen
verwehren
da irgendwelche parallelen und
beziehungen und bezüge lassen sie mich
kurz bei dieser selbstbestimmung bleiben
sie sagen im interview dass sie srf
kultur im vorfeld gegeben haben sagen
sie ja aber auch das könnte auch sein
dass eine depressive person selbst
bestimmt diese möglichkeit wird jetzt
denkt man natürlich depressiv dass
jemandem effekt handlungen da ist jemand
nicht wirklich bei sich erläutern die
das noch einer
man muss unterscheiden es gibt
sicherlich akut phasen und jemanden der
keine solchen wunsch äußert ist der
nicht einfach als authentischer
autoritative wunsch anzusehen
es gibt aber allerdings auch bei
depressiven phasen eben die in denen sie
nachdenken können in ruhe rational
nachdenken würden wie wir die situation
nur zum schluss kommen dass sie so nicht
mehr weiterleben wollen beispielsweise
menschen die über jahre an schweren
depressionen leiden solche fälle gibt es
die zum schluss kommen dass sie so nicht
mehr
weitermachen möchten wobei übrigens
gesagt werden muss dass sind relativ
wenige fälle in unserer praxis sind
nach den ergebnissen die ich die die die
vorliegen drei prozent der der der
suizidfälle die wir die wir begleitet in
der schweiz haben das ist ein kleiner
anteil
das hat sicherlich auch damit zu tun
dass das schwierig entscheidungen sind
aber prinzipiell zu sagen dass jemand
der depressiv ist nicht in der lage ist
freiwillig zu entscheiden dass sein
leben nicht mehr vorgehen will
dort gehen soll scheint mir gerade weil
sie falsch zu sagen ja ich glaube bei
dieser autonomie frage ist es halt
einfach auch noch mal wichtig zu sehen
an was binden wir eigentlich den begriff
von autonomie also binden wir den an
reine vernünftigkeit dann haben wir
irgendwie überhaupt keine menschen die
autonom sind außer vielleicht so ganz
einzelne historische weise in der antike
die es aber auch nur dem gerücht
nachgegeben hat also der mensch ist ja
auch in seinen autonomen entscheidungen
die vernünftig überlegt sind immer auch
ein emotionales tier und darum ist
natürlich auch also wir heiraten auch
nicht aus reinem vernunftsgründen wir
machen eigentlich fast alles was ihr tun
nicht aus reinem vernunftsgründen das
heißt das argument hier ist eine
affekthandlung oder hier sind emotionen
mit im spiel
das ist nicht ein argument was die
autonomie einer handlung untergräbt also
weil sonst wäre keine unserer handlungen
autonome dar da bin ich jetzt gerade
hellhörig also eigentlich sagt man da
gerade diese freitodbegleitung darf
natürlich nicht ausdruck einer
affekthandlung sein und sie sagen jetzt
ist alles immer irgendwie eine
affekthandlung also affekthandlung ist
natürlich das noch mal so ein
juristischer begriff der sozusagen also
spezifisch geht es ja darum bordeaux
klimaeffekt also dann kann ich irgendwie
von meinen emotionen überwältigt wurde
das ist sowieso kompliziert aber es ist
doch ehrlich gefährlicher weise so dass
der mensch nicht nur ein rationales
sondern auch ein emotionales tier ist
und er kann er muss sicher gründe
angeben können für seine rationale
entscheidung natürlich darf er nicht
sozusagen außer sich sein er darf nicht
geistig weggetreten seien aber dass auch
gefühle für unsere entscheidungen ja
auch für unsere vernunft in gewisser
weise das mit einfärben dass es richtig
das heißt wenn ich kann auch ein gefühl
haben dass mir das leben sozusagen in
diesem zustand ich muss das nicht
einzeln versagen werde geprüft wenn es
braucht die entsprechenden dokumente und
dann könnte man als zusätzliches
kriterium nach
einfügen dass der sterbewunsch stabil
sein muss ja verließ man wäre das für
sie zulässig also folgen im einspieler
haben ja gesehen diese frau leidet ich
glaube ja ein parkinson im
entsprechenden tatort das heißt die haut
tatsächlich eine krankheit die
fortschreitet es geht ihr nicht gut sie
habe diesen sterbewunsch würden sie
sagen das kann ein selbstbestimmter
sterbewunsch seien in diesem sinne ja
ich würde ja auch nicht ausschließen ja
das ist natürlich selbst wieder
selbstbestimmte sterben wünsche gibt die
habe nur probleme damit dass wir von
außen glauben relativ einfach
feststellen zu können was plausibel und
das nicht plausible gründe sind ja denn
wir aus der innenperspektive jemanden
der verzweifeltes oder der angst hat
oder der leiter der schmerzen hat ist
das alles plausibel dass er sich hier
jetzt tatsächlich wünscht um dieses
leids diesen schmerz diese nicht mehr
vorhandene perspektive zu beenden
das heißt dass ich hier keine wirklichen
kriterien die darüber befinden könnten
das ist das eine das andere ist also die
praxis der sterbehilfe etwa in den
niederlanden in belgien hat gezeigt dass
wir diese gründe in den letzten satz es
gibt seit 67 jahren immer weiter
aufgeweicht haben das kann man immer
mehr plausible gründe dazu bis hin zur
depression eines 16-jährigen den ersten
liebeskummer hat und die diesem
liebeskummer sich töten will warum nicht
er wer würde hier sagen wollen geht
nicht
das sind keine probleme durch eine
organisation oder sterbehilfe opposition
würde ein entsprechendes gesuch
gutheißen wegen liebeskummer naja also
wenn psychische psychisch schwere
psychische störung nicht einmal
erwachsen ich sagen es gibt es gibt
mittlerweile assistierten suizid auch
für minderjährige in manchen ländern
also daran merkt man ja daran nicht mehr
wie denn das team aus aber nicht das
gefunden hätte eine diagnose einer
terminalen krankheit
ich würde sagen in der schweiz ist uns
ganz klar dass niemand der in eine
situation der verzweiflung sich an der
sterbehilfeorganisation wendet ein auf
dass man auf die nein geht das ist gar
keine frage dass das das dass das eine
dass das geschieht einfach nicht und das
andere ist man muss ja
genau hinschauen was die gründe sind
welche die leute nennen die jetzt
betroffen sind
und das hat der igel ist es grund dass
man diagnose terminale krankheit und die
folgen davor fürchtet beispielsweise sie
haben eine diagnose dass sie noch einige
monate leben können und viele leute
wollen dann diese endphase nicht mehr
durchstehen müssen das ist nach wie vor
wegen sitzt eine bearishe standard
gründen der genannt wird darüber hinaus
gibt es auch noch solche einschätzungen
wie dass man die kontrolle über sich
selber verliert das man nicht mehr das
gefühl hat dass das leben das man lebt
das eigene leben ist das sind die gründe
die faktisch genannt werden bevor wir
hier irgendwelche geschichten erzählen
und das sind auch die gründe auf die
sterbehilfeorganisation eingehen und
wenn jemand liebeskummer kann ich nur
sagen wird dass da ja krank um das
vielleicht noch deutlich zu machen auf
eine krankheit die sowieso zum tod
führen wir bis eine tödliche krankheit
vielleicht um die sache noch einmal
einen schritt doch weiter zudrehen und
vielleicht herrn ließ man wie so ein
bisschen recht zu geben dass es
vielleicht sowas geben könnte wie einen
daumenbruch könnte man ja die frage
stellen gibt es nicht auch eine debatte
die in die richtung geht zu sagen na ja
es muss nicht unbedingt wirklich eine
urteilsfähigkeit vorliegen es gibt bei
exit an der generalversammlung im
letzten frühjahr die diskussion darüber
aber noch erweitern möchte ob zb demente
personen die wissen dass sie eine
demente demenz erkrankung haben noch als
urteilsfähige eine entsprechende
patientenverfügung unterzeichnen
ob die dann wenn sie dann dement sind
und eben eigentlich nicht mehr urteils
trotzdem noch in den suizid begleitet
werden dürfen exit hat sich dagegen
entschieden das ist nicht erlaubt
gemessen exit statuten aber
beispielsweise haben schon erwähnt in
den niederlanden ist sogar aktive
sterbehilfe erlaubt also auch das töten
von schwerstkranken menschen die nicht
urteilsfähig sind finden sie dass aus
ihrer sicht richtig sagen dass ich ein
problem und zwar einfach weil man nicht
antizipieren kann
was man für präferenzen haben wenn man
dann mal so weit ist als wenn man die
elemente bands aus gebrauchten ist das
gilt aber generell für
patientenverfügungen ich sehe da ein
problem das man glaubt das irgendwie
vorweg nehmen zu können und da habe ich
schwierigkeiten was aber nichts
grundsätzlich zu tun hat mit mit mit mit
einem problem im blick auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben im gegenteil
gerade weisung selbstbestimmung geht
glaube ich müsste mir da vorsichtig sein
weil die dann zu dem zeitpunkt nämlich
nicht mehr vorliegt deshalb übrigens
auch ganz klar genau gab ich aus den
gründen abgelehnt worden ist von der
großen mehrheit ja ich meine das noch
mal einfach zu dieser debatte also es
geht ja doch schon auch bei exit also da
muss eine unheilbare krankheit vorliegen
das ist nicht einfach so dass ich aus
lust und laune mich zitieren kann das
ist nicht richtig der wieland street ist
natürlich möglich er kriegt terminale
krankheit ist keine bedingung gesetzlich
ist ja nichts geregelt in der schweiz
gibt es ja nur diese bestimmung es darf
nicht aus selbstsüchtigen motiven
geschehen und der rest ist den
sterbehilfeorganisationen überlasten und
der kreis wird über die termine
erkranken also dass man die lebensmüden
in einer menschheit sieht hat sich
entschieden so genannte lebensminister
also altersmüdigkeit wie man das nennt
mit einzubeziehen
genau möglich ich konnte gut aber ich
wollte es nur noch mal gegen den
16-jährigen angeht aber immer das andere
nicht ob das nur erwähnt weil ich das
gelesen habe dass das bei natürlichen
niederlanden und belgien möglich ist ja
wirklich möglich ist auch wenn es
vielleicht wären vortragen unfall wenn
ich hab mir das schreckt es ging um
psychische erkrankungen
aber ich frage natürlich
aber vielleicht können wir noch mal zu
dieser aporie kommen weil das ist doch
die tatsächliche aporie das ist auch das
was uns angst macht also mich beruhigt
die tatsache dass exit gibt sehr weil
ich denke ich kann dann sozusagen
ich kann dem alter und der schweren
krankheit aber auch diese
altersmüdigkeit mit einer gewissen
gelassenheit entgegen gehen weil ich
weiß es gibt gewisse zustände die ich
dann nicht mehr erleben muss wenn ich
sie nicht erleben will darum es wechselt
für mich auch eine so seien psychisch
beruhigende sache das beunruhigende ist
aber eben genau dieser bereich der eben
sehr stark mit demenz zu tun hat oder
mit daneben krankheiten die in einem
verlauf haben wo man dann nicht mehr
selber handlungsfähig ist und dass man
da da kommen wir
die sapori ich kann jetzt zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt bestimmt was ich nicht mehr
haben will und ich kann es aber dann zu
demjenigen zeitpunkt nicht mehr
durchsetzen und das ist eine aporie
natürlich ist es dann so wenn ich dann
noch gar nicht dement bin kann ich es
nicht mehr habe ich keinen freien willen
mehr und kann kein urteil mehr abgeben
und und diese aporie kommen wir nicht
raus und das finde ich aber auch etwas
was mich beunruhigt
darf ich dazu sagen ich stehe die
beunruhigungen allerdings nur ganz kurz
was steht dahinter hinter dieser
diskussion es ist natürlich so dass sehr
viele leute sagen wenn ich eine
sprechende diagnose habe alzheimer oder
demenz dann ich möchte das nicht
durchstehen müssen also das kommt nicht
von außen das ist nicht irgend etwas was
den leuten geredet wird sondern das ist
etwas was die leute selber artikulieren
man kann das auch nachvollziehen man
kann er nachvollziehen dass man selber
denkt ich möchte das nicht bis zum
letzten durchlebten und deshalb gerne
jemanden beispiel also adressieren
können das wäre ja dann das system
jemanden adressieren können das für mich
in die wege zu leiten das steht dahinter
es ist problematisch gebe ich zu aber
das steht dahinter und ich finde den
wunsch zumindest du die idee
verständlich wie man dazu kommt dass man
etwas sagen es gibt einerseits diese
debatte darüber eben darf man
suizidbeihilfe in anspruch nehmen soll
man suizid beihilfe leisten bei
terminal- erkrankten und das sind so die
moment in dem sie sagen herr schaber
ich möchte mir nicht zumuten noch massiv
zu leiden ich möchte nicht diesen
todeskampf durchstehen und so weiter was
könnten die ein beispiel seien viel
umstrittener ist eben der sogenannte
bilanz zieht diese altersmüdigkeit jetzt
ein bisschen angeklungen ist und diese
möglichkeit besteht auch in der schweiz
also eine freitodbegleitung zu wählen
wenn man einfach den eindruck hat für
mich ist es jetzt genug ich bin sehr
sehr alt ich mag nicht mehr wieder so
schön sagen die rundschau hat zwei
frauen porträtiert im jahr 2014 die
entsprechend denken und wir schauen uns
kurze sequenz an
[Musik]
ihren platz auf dem friedhof hat sie
schon ausgesucht das testament ist
geschrieben
rösli wende hat alles für ihren tod
vorbereitet die 88 jährige hat kaum
gebrechen allerdings merkt sie dass die
kräfte nachlassen wochen nur laufen und
so den gott das noch
deshalb halte das nie machen denn wenn
sie also wirklich einfach sterben
[Musik]
claire müller aus neuhausen will
ebenfalls mit hilfe von exit sterben das
einkaufen fällt ihr schwer
die beine wollen nicht mehr richtig die
augen lassen nach all das ist unangenehm
das leben sagt frau müller mache ihr
zunehmend weniger freude
[Musik]
wir sagen wir stand ich damals 102
verstehen sie die damen erließ nun ich
kann schon verstehen klar ich habe ob
das problem bei der ganzen debatte dass
man auf einer seite natürlich
individuelle schicksale verstehen kann
und auch die handlungsweise nicht daraus
resultieren und ich mir mal frage aber
was anderes ist das ja das ganze gleich
sagen also ein gesellschaftlich zu
sanktionieren zum normieren also
optionen zu schaffen die dann eine
eigene dynamik gewinnen können ja wenn
ich das sozusagen akzeptiere diese
bilanz suizid schon der name man dafür
gewählt hat deutet für mich an dass es
darum kann etwas anderes geht sondern um
mal geänderte lebensauffassungen das
leben als fitnessprogramm und dann das
fitnessprogramm zu stottern bekommt
beenden wir es so kann man denken
entspricht unserer ökonomischen logik
entspricht unser fitness und ideologie
entspricht das sagen unsere
perfektionierung strategie aber so muss
man nicht denken und in dem moment wo
das in der art und weise dann auch
gesetzlich legalisiert ist unser
gleichen mehr besteht meines erachtens
schon die gefahr dass das gleichsam
normativ wird ja hier ist es doch ein
individueller wunsch der nächste schritt
ist das jemanden der auch sozusagen
schwierigkeiten einkaufen hat aber nicht
exit in anspruch nehmen will dass mein
leben sagt war warum war warum quälst du
doch noch wäre es nicht viel einfacher
du hast ein wunderbares leben gehabt
dass erwartest ja noch diese vorjahre
und sagen wir jetzt nicht sagen wir
jetzt nicht das kommt nicht vor
das kommt natürlich vor wir kennen fälle
aus oregon auch ein land aus den
assistierten suizid zugelassen hat wo
alte menschen die an krebs erkrankt sind
und man krebstherapie angesucht hat und
man ihnen von ihrer versicherung klipp
und klar signalisiert hat krebs aber bis
zu teuer aber die kosten für
assistierten suizid übernehmen wir sehr
gerne wollen es nicht diese
möglichkeiten die sie in anspruch nehmen
sie würden es in einer solchen situation
dieser frau sozusagen verbieten weil sie
denken es könnte diesen dammbruch geben
es entsteht dann eine drucksituation
gesellschaftlicher art sagen wir so ich
würde es nicht verbieten kann man ja
auch nicht man kann den suizid nicht
verbieten ja ich habe mich fragen was
nicht man kann ihn ja das ist genau das
ist genau der punkt der was wir
sozusagen an tragischen konflikten in
dem einen wie in dem anderen fall uns
sozusagen ein handeln ja jetzt so ein
bisschen das gefühl wir wir können mit
mit mit wirklicher sozusagen dilemma
damit wirklich tragischen
konfliktsituationen nicht nicht mehr
umgehen wir wollen für alles eine
saubere lösung und manchmal habe ich das
gefühl und gerade wenn es um leben und
tod geht das entscheidendste hermann
haben wir dann schon das gefühl dass wir
in dieser also sozusagen effizienz
orientierten jetzt auch todes economy ja
uns damit dinge ein handeln die zu einer
gesellschaft führen können von der ich
nicht weiß ob ich in ihr tatsächlich
leben will was nicht dagegen spricht der
hand ich sehe da muss ehrlich sagen ich
sehe keine keiner kenne keine wirklich
einfache lösung ja und keine wirkliche
lösung die hier alle alle ebenen
betreffende was nicht klagen entspricht
dass ich solche vorstellungen und
wünsche natürlich nachvollziehen kinder
und ich meine wie sie richtig sagen
suizid ist ja nicht verboten das problem
dass wir nur haben zum beispiel in
deutschland wo es eine entscheidung
gegen suizid beihilfe stattgefunden hat
ist das humane form des suizids verboten
wurden also man kann sozusagen einfach
nicht dass hier nicht mehr haben
man muss es eben mit pistole machen oder
von der brücke springen und das ist also
und das ist finde ich eine schwierigkeit
dass man das unterbindet eine
möglichkeit es zu tun und ich finde
diese beispiele sehr schön wäre so sein
wenn man ein alter suite wenn man sagt
es ist genug
wo man das glaube ich sind auf ein
gewisser weise ja auch das was die
philosophen teilen wenn sie vom suizid
als autonome entscheidung also wir der
freitod wirklich als freier tod also was
seneca auch sagt also zu gehen wann der
richtige zeitpunkt ist und zwar nicht
aufgrund einer notsituation
es geht eben nicht darum dass ich
sozusagen kriminal krank bin und darum
jetzt
leighton nicht mehr erleben möchte ich
sage jetzt einfach es ist genug ich
werde müde und ich gehe solange das
leben noch gut ist weil es geht nicht
darum bloß zu leben sondern es geht
darum gut zu leben wenn man das kreuz
ist nicht alles so wunderbar ist der
punkt ist ja sicher sagen dem interview
auch bei bilanz suizid müssen die gründe
nachvollziehbar sein
jetzt frage ich mich schon ist das
nachvollziehbar und wenn ihr sagen ja
glaube ich verstehe ich was sie mein
herr ließ man dann könnte man sagen wenn
jemand einem erzählt ich bin einfach
auch so müde ich möchte meine großmutter
hat immer gesagt ich möchte dass der
liebe gott mich jetzt mal holen kommt
dann denkt man so das ist
nachvollziehbar aber wenn dann jemand
sagt ich habe jetzt angemeldet ich
möchte jetzt übermorgen aus dem leben
scheiden weil es auch mühsam mit dem
einkaufen und dann sagt man das ist
nachvollziehbar dann denkt man was
letztlich das klingt dann genau was
klingt dann fast ein bisschen so ja so
kann ich es verstehen dass es jetzt mal
reicht wenn die idee bei der
nachvollziehbarkeit ist die dass die
begleiter und helfer auch eine
verantwortung übernehmen sie übernehmen
wenn sie sich darauf einlassen schon
damit dass sie sich ins gespräch
einlassen
eine verantwortung für diese person und
das macht man ja generell wenn ich
jemandem helfen muss ich mir gelegen ist
das verantwortbar dass ich das tue und
deshalb scheint mir für diese art von
verantwortung die man sich selber ran
dann gegenüber hat als begleiter da
braucht man nur wahrnehmen wenn man eben
den entscheid oder die entscheidung oder
den wunsch nachvollziehen kann und das
kann man vielleicht muss man da ein
bisschen länger reden mit den leuten als
oder ein bisschen mehr einblick haben
damit man sieht doch das gar nicht
nachvollziehen ich gar nicht dass alles
nachvollziehbar ist sondern dass wir
natürlich gute von schlechten gründen
unterscheiden können die daten auch
keine schwierigkeiten
und ich denke auch in dem fall haben sie
auch spontan gesagt kann ich mir gut
vorstellen dass die person
wieso die person stellen oder eine
ärztin hat mir auch im vorfeld
geschrieben sie möchte nicht genannt
sein dass die patienten und patientinnen
habe die hat besitzen ein haus
die wissen dass wenn ich ins pflegeheim
kommen dass sie das haus verkaufen
müssen weil sie uns die kosten für die
pflege nicht bezahlt werden können die
kinder hätten aber gerne das haus und
für sie ist eigentlich relativ klar dass
sie lieber den freitod wählen weil sie
ansonsten dieses haus den kindern nicht
vormachen können denke nicht dass ihn zu
horror geschichten die wir jetzt hier
nicht weitererzählen sollten
oder denken sie ja das ist im bereich
des möglichen und es ist ja auch okay
sich zu überlegen ob man das haus seinen
kindern machen möchte das ist eine ein
grund der der heikel ist wenn man
zumindest so von 2k ist deshalb weil man
nicht weiß wie freiwillig an die
entscheidung ist die auf einen solchen
und beruht allerdings muss man auch da
sagen wenn man wenn man untersuchung zur
kenntnis nimmt es gibt untersuchungen
leute gefragt werden die eine
sterbewunsch artikulieren wieso sie das
tun spielt dieser grund zur zeit einfach
ein absolut untergeordnete rolle die
gründe sind einfach andere die leute
nennen und die frau hat auch nicht einen
solchen grund genannt sondern ja sagen
wir als beispiel
aber so richtig da dürfen sie ja nichts
sagen es gibt nicht so viele beispiele
deswegen da ist von renault fahren
sondern auch ethische problem löst sich
nicht dadurch dass es nicht viele bars
oder noch nicht weil ich sage der
großgewerkschaft gesagt der grund ist
halt ein wenig sicherung ob es für
zulässig heute wenn das der einzige
grund ist er jemand geld nein aber es
ist das problem ist philosophisch
gesehen damit der ibm nicht exakt
definieren könne als plausible gründe
ist ja kann ich solche fälle nicht
ausschließen und es gibt natürlich das
soziale dynamik das wissen wir
unter der ein solches feld zu nehmen
können ja und ich finde schon
interessant wenn ich das nur kurz sagen
darf was ich gesagt dann zu sagen dieses
der muss sich darauf einlassen der
sterbebegleiter versuchte ihm zu helfen
ja wie wir in solchen situationen heute
hilfe definieren und wie man etwa in der
forschung des vergangenen jahrhunderts
ausgesehen hat ich bin ja groß geworden
mit einem so jetzt intellektuell mit
einem der großen österreichischen
psychologen und psychiater und sieht
forscher erwin winkel für den war nach
der man sich ein leben lang nur zuzieht
und suizidalen mit selbstmörder damit
selbstmordversuchen beschäftigt hat
verdienen klar war
über 90 prozent der suizide und
suizidversuche artikulieren keinen
wunsch zu sterben sei es in sozialer
hilferufe an die umwelt und die frage
ist wer nicht gestalten wie eine umwelt
wo wir sorgen
diese 19 hilferufe interpretieren wir
jetzt sehr wohl und zwar konkret also
zweierlei dazu also ich wollte auch noch
was zum dammbruch als haben aber
gleichzeitig das ist ja genau der punkt
also organisationen wie exit sind ja
genau diejenigen die beraten und wo dann
eben auch 90 prozent der suizid wünsche
auch dann nicht im suizid enden weil
natürlich sozusagen die stadt verfall ja
das ist der fall also derzeit hat eine
wahnsinnig große anzahl von mitgliedern
und sie haben auch eine sehr große
anzahl von beratung in denen man den ein
sehr kleiner teil in einem tatsächlichen
begleiteten freitod endet also das ist
genau das ist es ist eine
vermenschlichung des vorgangs weil man
sich dann nicht zuerst von der brücke
werfen muss bevor einem mit dem und mit
einem spricht sondern man kann
tatsächlich zu exit geben und die
sprechen mit einem und dann macht man
das ich möchte an dieser stelle
vielleicht käme von exit sprechen doch
auch noch eine andere organisationen ins
feld vielen dignitas der chef und denke
nicht dass geschäftsführer von dignitas
ludwig minelli der betont beispielsweise
auch immer diese doppel nennen das sind
doppelmoral dass man sehr viel über
diese erfolgten freitodbegleitung und
spricht und dann 2014 1200 fälle
ungefähr und sehr sehr wenig über die
vielen suizidversuche und suizide die
passieren in affekthandlungen und er
engagiert sich mit seiner organisation
auch sehr für die prävention von
effektiven suiten das möchte ich einfach
noch einmal also ich finde dass das hat
ja der schriftsteller wolfgang herrndorf
in deutschland sehr eindrücklich
vorgeführte er seinen eigenen tödliche
krankheitsverlauf beschrieben hatten
sich zuletzt mit einer pistole
erschießen musste und eben diese diese
unmenschlichkeit dieser handlung also
diese beträchtliche gewalt gegen den
eigenen körper geben daran liegt dass
man nicht dass er nie man nicht zugang
hat zu einem mittel zu einem anderen
mittel und ich finde aber eben genau
diese funktion von sterbehilfe verein
und vielleicht ist das auch ein grund
warum sie von den kirchen mit skepsis
gesehen werden weil sie natürlich eine
seelsorgerische tätigkeit durchaus haben
oder sie sind eine sorgende also dass
ich diesen hilferuf nicht durch gewalt
am eigenen körper dass jetzt ein anderer
fall als der tödliche krankheit sondern
hilfe rufenden psychischen den diesem
wunsch nach suizid erst noch mit einer
dafür zuständigen organisation
besprechen kann und dann möglicherweise
diesen hilferuf in sozialer andere
richtung das erscheint mir eigentlich
eine tag großen gewinne dieser
organisationen zu sein also dass sie
ebenso eine art von rückversicherung
geben davor dass eben nicht diese
gewaltsamen handlungen verführt werden
jetzt haben sie wolfgang herrndorf
erwähnt dass der umstand dass in
deutschland eben diese sagen wir mal
dienen als geschäftsmässig ist mit
beihilfe verboten ist also die
suizidbeihilfe die organisiert ist die
gezielt angeboten wird zu unterscheiden
von gewerbsmäßig im sinne von geld damit
machen dass es auch in der schweiz
natürlich untersagt aber die
organisierte suizidbeihilfe ist verboten
in deutschland deswegen gibt es dieses
phänomen des sterbetourismus in die
schweiz hinein gesprächen in der schein
in england zb von dem ausdruck going to
switzerland ist analog mit sterben gehen
in der schweiz
es gibt tatsächlich eine beträchtliche
anzahl von menschen die in die schweiz
kommen um hier zu sterben um dieses
thema ist auch teil des tatorts lassen
sie mich noch einmal einen einspieler
bei ziehen aus dem tatort war geht es
darum dass eine person aus glaube ich
österreich kommt eine krebskranke person
die gerne die suizidbeihilfe in anspruch
nehmen würde kam nicht durchgeführt
werden weil auf die wohnung in der das
stattfinden soll ein anschlag verübt
worden ist und wir sehen hier wieder
sterbehelfer den kranken diese
mitteilung machen muss
lechner ich eine schlechte nachricht
sagen sie nicht das sind wir wegen ein
paar deppen das sterben verbieten wollen
auch die wohnung ist eine art anschlag
wir müssen den termin leider absagen
muss tut mir leid
es kommt nicht in frage wenn nicht hier
dann woanders wo ist mir egal wo ist mir
egal herr schaber
dieses phänomen des sterbetourismus ich
meine das ist ja grauenhaft muss man
doch einfach fahren die leute kommen
hierher und dann diese situation man
kann sich eigentlich auch nicht wirklich
noch einmal unentscheiden gut diese
situation ist es ist besonders
unangenehm aber grundsätzlich muss ich
ehrlich sagen sehe ich keine probleme
mit sterbetourismus sofern
sichergestellt ist dass diese menschen
so behandelt werden und so beraten
werden wie sie beraten werden müssen das
heißt sofern die sorgfaltspflichten von
denen wir noch reden sollte nichts
ausrichten der sterbehilfe
organisationen erfüllt werden sie ich
ehrlich gesagt keine schwierigkeit die
nationalität der menschen spielt keine
rolle sondern ihre individuelle
situation
das ist das was ich vorhin gesagt haben
ich glaube dass das die verantwortung
der städte die die handy begleiter oder
helfer wäre sie nennen übernehmen das
die damit gibt führt daran geknüpft ist
dass man erst ein geht auf den
sterbewunsch wenn der nachvollziehbar
ist dass man dafür sorgt dass der
sterbe- und stabil ist dass die
begründung auch stabil ist und nur zwei
dinge zu nennen
das gehört zur erfüllung von
sorgfaltspflichten die mir wichtiger
scheinen und die muss die müssen
gegenüber allen wahrgenommen werden
ob sie jetzt von ausserhalb der schweiz
wohnen das würde ich sagen es blau
ich weiß nicht ob das so einfach ist mit
sorge verpflichten ob die wirklich auch
immer erfüllt werden nicht nachricht
welche kriterien da dann tatsächlich
maske weg sind ist leider so schwammige
kriterien ja das ist mir viel zu wenig
präzise also was heißt ein dauerhafter
wunsch das heißt der dauerhafte zweimal
im monat jede woche täglich über drei
jahre
was heißt dass beständigen in
zusammenhang hat haben diesen menschen
keine schwankungen haben die nie zweifel
daran wissen die wirklich oder man stern
und es ist ja so dass man nach einem
also üblicherweise beispiel erfahren hat
dass man ein erstes gespräch geführt und
und und und dann erwartet und ein
zweites gespräch führt mit einer
gewissen zeitlichen distanz um diese
stoffe die aber zum glück ist auch
erklären gerne von diesen sterbehilfe
also eine selber aufgestellt es gibt ja
sozusagen keine konsensfähigen soweit
ich das weiß keiner konsensfähigen
tatsächlich einen strengeren
überlegungen oder oder vorgang aber sei
es drum ja ich habe nur sozusagen ein
bisschen zweifel aber zu sagen dass das
immer in dieser art und weise möglich
ist ohne irgendjemanden böse absichten
zu unterstellen und das andere was ich
zum thema sterbetourismus sagen weil ich
verstehe alle diese diese argument ja wo
sie haben selber gesagt oder menschen
ist nicht nur reine rationalität
emotional so als erster effekt eher
sterben als globales
dienstleistungsunternehmen da sträubt
sich sträubt sich einfach was ich mir
aber ich muss zugeben ich muss das erst
überlegen ob das auch eine rationale
grundlage hat ja ich glaube ich muss das
ist nicht nur eines
dienstleistungsunternehmen ist ich
glaube dass das eine reduktion ist ich
glaube dass auch fürsorgepflichten eben
das meine ich mit sorgfaltspflichten
erfüllt werden müssen überprüft es ist
nicht nur einfach so dass man dass man
sagt da sie wollen starten
jetzt waren einladen ich glaube dass die
sache anspruchsvolle auch durch länger
je mehr sich das dem er sich da wird ja
größer wird desto geringer falls aber
vielleicht könnte ja mal ist es in der
stärkeindustrie mach es doch nichts vor
wir haben der welt wir leben werden
welche phänomene auf anderen gebieten
ganz gesungen als nächstes wird in
dieser hinsicht industrialisiert also
also ich glaube über dieses dammbruch
problem müssen wir nochmal reden aber
ich würde zu gegen den sterbetourismus
hätte ich tatsächlich auch einen anwalt
um 2 ich habe das jetzt nun aus der
deutschen perspektive verfolgt weil ich
seit ein paar jahren in deutschland lebe
und selben anderen genau und ich für
mich ist eben so etwas wie sterbehilfe
sehr selbstverständlich und das war für
mich interessant zu sehen dass in
deutschland die diskussion so ganz
anders verlief und bis hin zu diesem für
meiner meinung nach wirklich unsäglichen
verbot im letzten november was auch
massiv am volkswillen vorbeigeht da
merkt man wieder mal deutschland hat
keine direkte demokratie also bei 70
prozent der deutschen oder 80 prozent
wären für eine liberale lösung aber das
parlament weiß es besser
sozusagen also da gibt es natürlich
diese ganzen religiösen traditionen und
das problem das wir jetzt haben in
deutschland haben wir faktisch eine
situation wo es sehr sehr schwer
geworden ist sich ein solches medikament
von einem arzt verschreiben zu lassen
weil ärzte fürchten müssen angeklagt zu
werden weil das geschäftsmäßige ein
schwammiger begriff ist als ein grad ist
ja eine geschäftsmäßig handelnde person
und wenn er das öfter macht ist es auch
auf wiederholung angelegt und das wir
jetzt haben wir müssen touristisch aktiv
werden wenn ich also ein sterbewunsch
habe und möchte keine pistole zur hand
nehmen muss ich ins ausland gehen und
darin liegt also das halte ich für eine
für deutschland eine schlimme situation
und tatsächlich kommen wir dann wenn
natürlich eine massive anzahl von
staaten restriktiv ist und nur wenige
liberal
dann kommen wir zu so industriellen
sachen und vor allem aber was machen
natürlich sozial es ist so sozial
selektiv also tourismus muss man sich
leisten können hätten sie gesagt
von marc da muss man schon sehen man
muss dann touristisch tätig werden da
wird natürlich ganz viele aus dem
bereich der palliativmedizin aufschreien
und sagen moment mal
es gibt natürlich noch die andere
möglichkeit die palliativmedizin und ich
kann wenn man bilanz zieht wählt weil
man nicht einkaufen gehen kann oder weil
man müde ist dann ist palliative
die natürlich keine lösung aber für
terminal- kranke patienten sagen viele
palliativmediziner haben wir doch
eigentlich bereits instrumente reicht
das nicht
es sei deshalb nicht eins bleibe ich
dass das das ist noch nicht alles
schmerzen wirklich entsprechend geheilt
und und kontrolliert werden kann aber
der ist in einem grundsätzlichen punkt
wenn das jemand nicht will
wenn jemand sagt alles wunderbar ich
möchte das jetzt nicht mehr ich möchte
mich keinen medizinischen behandlung
reiter unterziehen
dann ist die frage das war die noch
hinzufügen zu einer diskussion wir
vorhin hatten
hat man dann ein recht zu sagen wir
verbieten ihnen das oder wir bieten dir
das hat insbesondere da muss man mal
gefragt werden der staat ein recht zu
sagen das geht nicht und die beginnt
normalerweise wird immer von der
unterseite aufgezogen was wären die
personen in der pflicht da sich zu
richten ich würde sagen staat muss sich
rechtfertigen weil er leuten das
verbietet und faktisch tut er das sind
wie gelernt hier greift er in die
autonomie aller gesammelten 30 also was
die autonomierechte betrifft das hinge
ja auch sehr dass elektro wir wollen
einen schwerkranken vielleicht auch
psychisch aus diesem grund natürlich
ihre instabilen menschen durchaus den
freien willen zu gestehen über seinen
tod zu entscheiden aber einer
erwachsenen frau weil man nichts zu
gestehen ob sie einen körper an einem
freier verkauft oder nicht ja da ist
plötzlich von autonomie rechten keine
rede mehr
das heißt also wir sind da sehr sehr wir
sind sehr sehr nah aber es geht genau
auch um autonomie ja dann das zweite ich
möchte überhaupt mit dir zu sagen
religiösen hintergrund argumentieren
sondern erfordern und kann technischen
hintergrund wie stets den zusagen mit
dem universal der universalisierung der
prinzipien die dahinter stecken ja also
ich meine dieser dieser diese skepsis
gegenüber der selbsttötung hat auch
durch voraussetzung das argument dass
ich jetzt was einem selber nicht etwas
machen darf was ich mit anderen auch
nicht machen darf
aus recht beansprucht für milch
schätzungen ausnahmezustand das bin ich
wirklich in diesen situationen die große
ausnahme
also das ist ein problem was bei
legistischen regelungen natürliche rolle
spielen muss was nicht erspielen muss
bei wirklich individuellen also
sozusagen einzelentscheidungen und auch
wenn ich sozusagen diese möglichkeit
oder auch dieses
der suizid zugestehe in bestimmten
situationen
es stellt sich schon die frage folgt
daraus die pflicht zur beihilfe kann ich
jemanden tatsächlich sozusagen die
pflicht nehmen blieben und sterben du
musst ja wichtig für ende des gesprächs
lassen sie peter schafer vielleicht noch
das schlusswort zu diesem thema sprechen
gibt es eine pflicht wir sagen natürlich
gibt es natürlich nicht das büro ist
noch weniger was die frage ist nur ist
man berechtigt jemanden das verbieten
ist wird uns der staat dazu berechtigt
und die frage nur da muss ich noch los
das muss ich los
die frage stellt sich selbst dann wenn
man mit kant der meinung ist dass man
moralisch eine pflicht gegen sich selbst
verletzt wenn man sich wenn man sich man
sein leben beendet oder es beenden lässt
durch autorisierung von anderen selbst
dann weil nämlich dann auch selbst wenn
man das teilen würde
noch nicht klar ist dass der staat für
die art von moral das mit gewalt zwang
durchsetzen darf das ist nämlich alles
andere als klar dass nur so als
nebenbemerkung zukommt wenn man ich
danke ihnen sehr wir haben die wir sind
tatort gesprochen sind bei immanuel
kants gelandet kann steckt überall drin
wir haben noch zeit wie immer am
philosophischen stammtisch für unsere
philosophische tipprunden der herrlichen
was haben sie mitgebracht
ja ich ein buch mitgebracht über ein
thema das auf unsere frage heute berührt
aber weit darüber hinaus geht das thema
werte viel diskutiert andreas uhr sommer
hat eine kleine aber feine abhandlung
darüber geschrieben
es geht darum ob wir werte überhaupt der
benötigen und was werte sind und er
kommt zu dieser interessanten these das
lohnt sich das nachzulesen dass es werte
gar nicht gibt aber dass es trotzdem
drauf und werte sind sozusagen lebens
dienliche notwendige funktionen die
allerdings als fiktionen natürlich
unglaublich variabel und variantenreich
sehen sein können und wie schnell sich
werte verändern haben wir auch in
unserer heutigen diskussion gesehen
danke wirklichen tipp ich habe ein buch
mitgebracht eines amerikanischen
philosophen der als samuel schaeffler
das ist letztes jahr bei socom 4 besetzt
erschienen und der titel ist leicht
irreführend
scheint darum zu gehen das leben nach
dem tod dass ihn das des individuellen
todes darum geht es aber nicht denn es
geht um die frage was uns eigentlich der
umstand bedeutet dass die menschheit
weiter lebt und wie wichtig es ist
möglicherweise für uns dass die
menschheit noch weiterlebt und zwar weit
wie bei unser eigenes leben hinaus und
ich finde die frage interessant und auch
das was er damit untersuchen will
nämlich wie unsere werte beschaffen sind
was für menschen von bedeutung ist das
ist nämlich das worum es letztlich geht
und ich kann das buch nur wärmstens
empfehlen assist gutgeschrieben
das ist auch verständlich geschrieben
und eine frage die man bislang glaube
ich noch nicht gut und richtig
reflektiert hat
vielen dank ich habe heute einen film
mitgebracht magento oder das meer in mir
schon ein bisschen in älterer film 2005
heraus gekommen habe damals auch den
oscar erhalten für den besten
ausländischen film fremdsprachigen film
der film ist ein wunderbares porträt
einer realen existierenden figur einer
person die mittlerweile nicht mehr lebt
ramon ihr habt eine schwimm unfall ist
danach tetraplegiker ans bett gefesselt
er selber findet sein leben nicht mehr
lebenswert ich nicht mehr lebenswert und
er wünscht sich aus dem leben zu
scheiden
das wird ihm verwehrt aufgrund der
rechtslage in spanien
und er kämpft um seinen tod er kämpft
auch um sein leben gekämpft um diese
krankheit um die existenz ein
unglaublich zärtlicher film ein sehr
ergreifender film ich glaube einer der
ergreifendsten filme zum thema keine
leichte kost aber unbedingt anschauen
ja ich habe dieses buch mitgebracht das
ist der briefwechsel zwischen hannah
arendt und günther anders zwei große
philosophen und intellektuelle des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts von denen nicht
alle wissen dass sie auch mal
miteinander verheiratet waren und den
1930 er jahren
sie waren dann aber danach auch gute
freunde sind sie geblieben und vor allen
dingen waren sie sehr eng verbunden mit
einander durch diese flucht das ist ein
thema was uns derzeit sehr beschäftigt
wo es hannah arendt auch wieder nahe
gekommen ist die sich sehr viel
der eigenen flucht auch beschäftigt hat
in ihrem großen text the fugees und da
in diesen briefwechsel der sehr
fragmentarisch ist nicht alles erhalten
ist von den briefen aber es sind diese
briefe von panama und aus von 1940 41 wo
sie wo ihr diese flucht gelingt aus
frankreich nach new york und wo günther
anders er hilft ihr ex mann der schon in
den staaten ist und man sieht diese ganz
kleinteiligkeit was es eigentlich
bedeutet wie man ein visum kommt wie man
leute die noch feststecken in frankreich
oder in deutschland versucht
rauszukommen
es ist sehr sehr eindrückliches
zeithistorisches dokument auch vielen
herzlichen dank und danke für die
diskussionsthemen suizidbeihilfe wird
uns auch philosophisch bestimmt weiter
beschäftigen dankeschön nächste woche
spricht unser gast moderator wolfram
eilenberger mit dem einflussreichen
politiker parag khanna der unter anderem
barack obama beraten hat in der
sternstunde erklärt er wie die
globalisierung unsere weltkarte
verändert deshalb steht er die neuen
länder sind und warum wir auf eine welt
ohne grenzen zu steuern
und jetzt gleich lade ich sie ein in die
sinnliche welt des tanzes der schweizer
choreograph martin schläpfer weiß ganz
offensichtlich lieber let inszeniert
sein will die preise häufen sich nämlich
das publikum jubelt unser film porträt
zeigt den großen künstler auch von
seiner philosophischen seite
ich bedanke mich für ihr interesse und
wünschen ihnen einen guten sonntag
[Musik]